hey guys today we have almond Bartram
co-founder of Socialcam triple bite and
he is here to talk to us about hiring so
could you just give us a quick intro
about what you've worked on cool so I
joined justin.tv fresh out of school in
2009 it was just 25 folks and I went to
the roller coaster of the early days of
justin.tv and there I work mostly on the
the video system and I think that my
first sort of taste of hiring you know
we were as at the end of that we were
hiring pretty aggressively and that was
my first realized how uh how much noise
the reason hiring process that's okay
yeah and then then I was part of a
spin-off of Socialcam and that was a
video sharing app mmm I did that for
about three and a half years and we
required by Autodesk in 2012 and I
worked there until 2014 and then took a
bit of time off and started a trilobite
coop and so triple by just for context
for people can you explain sure so I
yeah so we're a recruiting startup so we
help startups hire engineers okay and so
and engineers apply to us and then we do
sort of a full interview with with them
uh you know past the engineers who are
good and match them with with companies
where they have a high-poverty of doing
well cool so people ask us a million
questions about hiring recruiting all of
it in general let's assume that you're
you know a early-stage startup what
should companies be looking for in an
engineer there's not there's not a crisp
answer to that I think the sort of the
pickiest answer I can give to that is
you have to decide what it is you want
to look for and then you have to
effectively look for that so sort of the
status quo actually I think there's sort
of an important roots here
most companies think that they are
trying to hire good engineers that's
that that's what they say to themselves
um and that and end day but they don't
realize is that you know company a is
definition of a ganja near is
significantly different from company
these and so what you have is a
situation where everyone has this
definition in mind and they're all
different and this is a big source of
noise so for example if one you know
company thinks that engineers need to be
you know very fast and productive and be
able to show that in an interview and a
different company thinks that engineers
need to be you know very intellectual
and be able to deeply understand
computer science topics and talk
chrisley about that I what happens is
sort of all of the all of the awesomely
productive and you know engineers very
practical not necessarily in strong
academics who applied second company
sale and you know all of the all of the
very academics you could totally solve
all your hard problems but maybe aren't
quite as flashy in that way no web
environment engineer supply of the first
company also fail and so it's you know
what comes out a bit of a larger stage I
think the obvious answer is you want to
have both those people and so it's about
building a process that can identify
more broadly different types of skill
for smaller companies I think you're
more situation where you may well
actually only want one of those folks
you may well you know the thing that's
on your company back may well be
productivity and we need someone's gonna
come in and be productive and and and
sort of bang out code and if that's the
case you know you need to realize that
is it not important that everyone you
hire be strong in computer science and
if you are you know a company where
you're facing security issues and you
know really clean code with precise code
and in solving hard problems is
important to you then you know at an
early stage and it probably makes us how
to process that skews more in that
direction and so do you have general
advice for people that come to you guys
a triple byte or just you as a friend
advisor for diagnosing like what kind of
engineer is a good engineer for your
company what it like what do you tell
people we don't know so it's funny we're
we're really good at situation actually
I think most most people have strong
preconceptions so we we're more often in
the situation of sort of
broadening people's people's vision of
what a scale engineer can be but I think
the obvious yet me something limited to
masseur go back to the question well I
think what happens a lot is the missus
the mistakes that needed to fall into is
we people are interviewing an engineer
they tend to ask about the things that
they are the best at this is overlap
between the things that you're the best
and the things that you think are most
important
yeah ever it like you like every
engineer thinks the things that they
know are kind of the core of the
discipline and so you ask everyone who
you interviewed those questions you by
yourself toward hiring engineers who
have those skills they join your team
they asked to play interview the same
type of question so the whole
organization can grow in a direction
that might not make sense mmm okay um
you know it's very complicated because
there plenty of examples of companies
with you know the define engineering
cultures that have worked out very well
so for example Google you know
intentionally or unintentionally growing
very much in a computer scientist
direction and that's obviously worked
out you know very well for them yeah um
you know I okay you know there are there
are other companies nowise today that
that I don't want to say names but those
are companies that that take a complete
opposite take a very human productivity
friendly approach and it also it seems
accessible excellent companies and so
you know answering that question is not
basically that cases on both sides I
think as that you know when you're
hiring your first employers I think you
need to just basically you know try to
decide what's holding us back
yeah and yeah and so say like say I'm
trying to vet this pool of engineers and
they all like fit the the certain rubric
that I've created right yeah but maybe
one of them did a bootcamp and have some
projects and then one of them you know
went to a great school has a CS degree
so how do you how should I think about
you know credentials and experience boot
camps versus CS degree I don't think are
all that different now okay that's
obviously a forceful statement so I
think I think experience matters more
than
where you got your education right so
someone could fresh out of a thought of
a siesta program who doesn't have
internships it's still essentially a
junior engineer um and perhaps they may
have any more academic slant to what
they've studied than some out of a boot
camp but both those people lack
real-world experience
I think catalyzing is that differently
than someone who has you know working
industry for five years and can can own
projects like the big soso bit so you
still that you can most easily measure
in interview is ability to think through
small properties small problems quickly
that's really what you do is can
evaluate okay the skill that you need in
an employee is the ability ability to
solve large sprawling problems well but
over a long period of time and there's
obviously a correlation there
you know it's not it's not you know we
use integers as a proxy of evaluating
actual skill because there is the
correlation there but the correlation is
not perfect and an interesting
observation is that people who are fresh
out of university and boot camps
actually in many cases because they've
been practicing are better at the kind
of problem that gets asked incident then
you're very senior you know 810 years of
experience at large company engineer
what the senior engineer has typically
is experience making our character
decisions owning projects gathering
requirements carrying out whole process
through and so okay how do we evaluate
for that it's super-hard
basically what ends up happening and
this is this is honestly unfair is that
experience get you gets get on is issues
as a proxy for that is something that
we're folks get a lot of filled by on
but what you know this is very strange
actually if you are if you're a V or
five years of experience it's it's just
easier to pass the interview you will
get a job offer you know after a were
sport you people think maybe that senior
engineers you know you know you expect
their senior intention a should perform
better than the Indigo and that's
actually not generally true the bars
getting a job offer goes down as you
have sort of a present looking resume
and and didn't it's not you know it's
not irrational the part of the companies
it's just the reality
sure okay and so then when you guys are
like pre
training these people for triple bite
for example like what are you looking at
what are you having them do I so we the
approach that we take is to evaluate as
much as we can in isolation and be aware
what we're evaluated so we explicitly
evaluate programming just proving
creativity given a relatively you know
aspect out problem so example we like
describing an algorithm to solve a
problem it's not super math they just
choose the set of steps they have to do
can the candidate take that and put you
know render it into well working
well-structured code mm-hm
many interestingly junior folks actually
often do better than senior folks at
that sort of problem we then separately
do a evaluation of sort of academic
computer science skills you know I mean
you know is the engineer knowledgeable
about about about about computer science
and about that approach to problem
solving
we then separately one thing that we
took some strife actually is we do a
debugging section and so we give the
candidate a large code base and that has
some some bugs and we ask them to sort
of take take some time digging in the
codebase and then try to find and fix
these bugs and I think it did such a
great job of solving some of of those
problems basically because of the you
know this is a skill that comes from
experience that it's often missed by
more and more additional DeBeers um and
then finally we do a system design
section so you know here's a talk here's
who's you know here's the requirements
design a production web system to
Southsiders requirements okay now i'm
going to change the requirements you
know okay how do you adapt your design
how do you talk about trade-offs in all
that's done remotely because the
person's at home right yes we did we do
this all over Google hams
okay and so what's a reasonable amount
of time for someone to just like go
through one of these exercises are they
all widely different or you go to go
through our exercises mm-hmm
our reviews are about two hours in
length and so we spend about 30 minutes
on each section okay cool and you find
this like a very strong data set in
terms of correlating how successful
their yeah what we've done about we've
done about 2,000 integers over the last
year and a half and so we've been able
to sort of drill in on the parts that
are
that are most predictive and cut time
often shortened it I think if you're
starting from scratch you run it about
about twice the amount of time to get
you all that stuff okay and so what like
so having gone through all these
interviews at this point was there
anything that you thought was really
important in the beginning or something
that's like very common in the valley
that many people think is important that
isn't really important too much reliance
on a single question so the sort of the
classic interview format in in tech
companies is you know a number of one
hour 45 minutes one hour sessions hmm
and in Austin engineers pick the
questions themselves and they're usually
with little nuggets of like I I know
there's much pejoratively called brain
teasers I don't I don't think I like
almost no one actually asked brain
teasers they're they're more like
legitimate programming problems but they
are though nuggets of difficulty like
how do you you know given a string of
parenthesis how do you turn up there
well mash okay given multiple types how
do you turn it on match if you don't see
no you know that's a classic and good
question um and it ends up there's just
a huge amount of noise if you just take
a bunch of candidates and in a
controlled setting have them all answer
you know three or four of these
questions you'll see it's just there's
some correlation but there's way less
correlation than you would think
um and companies and honestly I I
believe that's in my previous you know
when I was like you you have this
question you ask another question and
you see this variation you assume oh the
people who asked this question well must
be smart and good programmers and people
will get totally tripped up it must not
be um and then you actually like inspect
that you see that there's this huge
amount of noise and like we have this
pretty incredible lens on this this
because we exaggerate and adjust pretty
rigorously and then send up to multiple
companies and see what happened get
detailed feedback and so yeah is that
feedback from the actual interview
process or then once they're placed you
actually know as well how they're doing
both okay but I'm talking about the
about the interview process okay we so
we you say engineers we send in to
companies and then they do the interview
there and we get feedback and it's just
pretty incredible how how how much
disagreement there is so a candidate who
you know does really well at one company
and they get total this is what the best
personal even even in months as their
Iraq star goes on to fail an interview
about some at somewhere else and like a
pretty interesting stat we dug up is I
compared the rate of agreement between
interviewers at companies with a data
set of users reviewing movies online and
the numbers were acted with basically
and the integrator agreement was was was
equivalent so basically these knowing
that an engineer did well at one company
gives you about as much you know
information about whether that engineer
is you know skilled as you know knowing
whether you know the New York Times film
critic you know rated 12 years a slave
as excellent dirt or terrible so okay
maybe you don't have an answer to this
but say I'm really good at brain teasers
where should I interview I load your
company's probably larger companies so
and this makes a certain amount of okay
this is all very complicated and there's
a certain amount of sense so bigger
companies so brain teasers always
introduce noise but we've found that
bigger companies rely more on that type
of interview and I do that partly partly
for some rational reasons so bigger
properties care more about measuring
your innate ability and less about
measuring whether you can jump into
their particular code base and be
productive on day one but way more
likely that a smaller company is going
to say we're using you know Ruby on
Rails we need a very black tip rails
developer you know come take this
interview you know and and and organize
you how well universe maybe how about
you can work on our actual code base
okay mom whereas the big company you
know Facebook Dropbox Apple Google are
more likely to say we care about smart
people and you know within the confines
of the noise of your process they're
trying to identify intelligence rather
than specific experience I mean they
also have like capacity time to Train
yeah for cycling whereas like a small
company in a way okay and then like
prior one of the questions
what about skills that people don't
think it's
that are strongly correlated to a
successful engineer relatively easy
problem-solving so we've we've so we
have found that asking pretty easy
interview questions is often more
generally predictive than asking harder
interview questions and so so so iterate
this down there are kind of there are
two sources of signal from asking a
question you can get signal on whether
the candidate comes up with the right
answer and you can get signal on whether
they you know would let they struggle
how is your heart is them to solve the
problem and so we square both these
things from us of questions and done
this for again thousands of candidates
and what we found is that you could go
in and look at how much you know the
individual score on one question we're
asking correlates with how the candidate
does on the job and what we've found is
that as you expect um you know getting a
question right is is correlated with the
agenda and as you would expect being
able to answer a question easily is
correlated with being you engineer but
there's also of course you know uh false
negatives right so there are great
engineers who fail answer your questions
and their grants need to struggle with
questions and if you if you do if you
look at it like like the actual
predictive ability you know rather just
the correlation of getting on the right
side right the sweet spot is actually
far lower on the scale than most people
intuitively think and so yeah can you
give you like a couple examples of what
those easy or questions might be yeah
sure just ask like like saying like you
know we want you to create a checkers
game absolutely no you know no large
that in complicate just a class that has
a board as a greatest got pieces pieces
move around this is really a pretty
mundane straightforward task that
actually ends up being you know how well
can they to do that ends up being a more
stable predictor of engineering skill
then sort of you know here's you know
here's a you know here's the your
sentence that consists of a list of
words all gland together and you define
the optimal way to you're given a
dictionary it breaks apart into words
mmm
the second problem is you know visit
being a graph source problem that can be
you know optimize with you know
memorization of them.i programming the
second game the second problem right
carries more information getting the
first problem right but with a great
high false negative right yeah
and so the first problem is it actually
being a better general predictor of
engineering skill and so is there a way
if I'm like getting ready for a new you
know I'm going to go to another company
I'm going to get ready to interview do
you recommend people train in any
particular way or is because like you're
going for that sweet spot of easy
questions like you just have to be smart
enough to do it like what do you tell
people so be in general yeah if I'm
going to prep to do some interviews what
would I do so I mean I guess there's
those two questions there one is what I
think for companies I think are doing a
good job interviewing and then maybe
four I think some sort of status quo is
in general it sounds were coming from
I'm so very very advice for new grads
and for experienced folks okay so let's
let's break up a part yeah new grads
okay for new grads I would say you know
make sure you're solid with sort of the
class the classics you know stuff that
soap so you know breadth first search
you know hash table we're going to keep
the Gordon's what classical computer
science yeah a surprising percentage of
a new question ends up being slightly
obscured applications of sort of those
but especially you know hash tables and
then breadth-first search those those
two things by themselves represent
probably forty percent of the questions
that are asked the most companies and so
you need to know those but actually many
new grads are already pretty solid on
that because they've been being drilled
throughout school the second thing is I
practicing writing code under understood
under stress so working out a big
problem over time it's very different
then you have ten minutes or 30 minutes
here's a you know because a marker write
in a wipe or even here's a you know
laptop program on it and so just you
know that things correlate this feels
correlate but you can improve your
performance by practicing so totally you
know put in you know 30 minutes a day
finding some new questions online and
giving yourself a time limit and sort of
trying to solve motor vessel situations
and are very good were like resources
that people can look for we get anything
in particular I mean the classic ones
right so Socratic coding in view has a
pretty good list of questions it's the
other advice in that book I don't think
really applies to startups very much but
the questions are good and then there
are a bunch of a bunch of sites online
that have lists any good cake is one
that that I've seen I think it's
high-quality an interesting aside to
this though is that most companies
actually want you to do these things so
it's not complete would prefer that all
their candidates we prefer we totally
prefer if we try to design or interview
in such a way that there's no impact
right we don't really want to be
measuring if you've been cramming on
algorithms um but what many companies
want to measure is like max scale max
potential I'll so they would they would
actually much rather see you you know in
a state where you your role parent
Imperial right in there rather than the
state when you have the potential to
understand it but but forgot about it
yeah I mean what you know a interesting
trend that's happening in industry is
company companies being more upfront
about what they're asking so Facebook
for example has started providing any
sort of interview prep class to everyone
who applied so that is sort of going
over the material it's part of you finds
it encouraging because it is moving in a
better direction but that's also
discouraging because it's like really
sucky that you have to like take a class
yeah I just wonder like if it's
filtering for those types of people
right who are just like looking for like
I don't know what to do I don't know
what to do it's like well if you apply
here you could take the class and then
like take it like let me hold your hand
the whole way through your life right
yeah okay okay so say I am going to
interview at a bigger company is there a
way to prep to do well with the
brainteaser stuff yeah practice so so
again there are some words that are
thrown around describing any questions
that aren't brain teachers are pretty
rare some companies probably have asked
things like you know the golf balls in a
747 but that's really very rare much
more common is application of a computer
science idea to up to a practical
problem okay and there still is this
leap of
required in many cases I think those are
bad that need questions right you don't
like the you know I company should try
very hard to ask questions weather is
not like there's one thing that has to
be grass until that grass that the
problem feels impossible um but that you
know but hard applicator you know sort
of private application of computer
science topic represents a significant
majority of questions that big companies
and so was so when I was in college I
interviewed it one of those like big
management consulting firms and they did
have all those questions like humans
like prepping for it and I didn't get
the job and I did okay unlike the stupid
you know ping-pong ball question I don't
feel bad one thing one number we have
that's interesting is that the engineers
who do the best that companies go on to
pass about 80% of their interviews but
not a hundred no almost no one passes
more than eight and everybody's at
companies all right and yeah so so you
know one big a bit of advice to everyone
is just like don't feel that if you fail
you know it's really not a referendum on
your skill I'm very happy to have not
gone in that direction so what about the
role of like you know projects someone's
portfolio of like side projects are
there certain types of side projects
that across the board are attractive to
companies or is it like you know say say
I'm applying for a job at stripe and
like I did you know X payment type
project and that would be more
attractive to them so across the board
are there things that are interesting
let me let me talk about my question
mingle fact but I think you know the
right name companies to do it so
companies don't actually pay very much
attention to side projects okay except
for at the screening stage so resume
screen you know you can't it applies to
company companies decide you click on
any of the person at all and there's
some adverse selection bias and who
applies the companies and there's this
big stream of candidates and so at any
company there's this huge game coming in
and they have to decide somehow and so
they do that on based on resume screens
and it comes down to pretty dumb
credential stuff right if you've worked
at a top company you've gone to a top
school or in some cases if you have a
project but the catches right that's
that's impressive and so it's I Preston
help a lot there okay um but they are
very rarely given way
the actual interview and I think it's
actually probably the right decision so
people who have slidepark sometimes feel
bad about this yeah but but but the
reason it's the right decision is that
most engineers don't have side projects
most juniors have been have you know
been working at a company and it's all
proprietary code and there's very little
they can show that's you know eight out
of ten and even you don't that situation
and having a consistent process
consistent fair you know like
contingency is the first goal is not
going to be processed so that you know
they you know the big problem is that
the process is not use the consistence
we've made consistent then you can
optimize it you come and having this
sort of other process we look at
projects interest is noise and it's also
just really hard to do so you can't tell
if someone spent you know a weekend on
the project hosted working out so it's
like the last 10 years we have we
literally see both pretty regularly we
talked about their projects in some
gated over weekend or this has been my
you know abiding passion for the last
ten years let alone like who actually
contributed yeah delivery and and and
you know things like coding clothing
right it's actually it's startlingly
hard to look at a big bit of code and
decide if you think the program who
wrote it is is skilled hmm maybe just
again like there's so much context you
can't tell us what bugs they spend hours
over you like finding me like finding
bugs like not good enough look at a code
like immediately find the bugs um yeah
and I yeah and so you know for that
reason for all those reasons you know
the side projects are useful so if you
if your problem as an engine if you
ignorant about engineering if you're
applying for jobs and you're beating
speed not allowed to resume stage doing
these projects probably helps mmm I'm
doing part of the great way that
obviously increase your skills and that
will reflect it in better performance on
interviews mmm but I I don't think
projects have a very big role in in the
actual interview and so what other
things should I think about if I am
being screened out like say like you
know I'm getting a call back from like
one out of ten yeah what should I do
slideshow bite
you know other otherwise yes that's why
projects help
I just sucks right it's not it's not
it's not malice on the part of the
companies you know like it's they're one
of the applicants and so they use these
sort of crude filters and that's I think
the big thing that we're focused on is
trying to figure out how to directly
measure the skill and so that we don't
have to rely on on you know filters like
where someone's worked or what school
they went to and what about things like
you know for example locations let's say
I live in Salt Lake City and I'm
interested in getting a job possibly a
Facebook should I put like San Francisco
on my resume and just like fly out for
an interview
do you have general advice in that area
big companies don't care at all where
you're based they have a flat people in
you know by the hundreds every week okay
um smaller companies I do show a slight
preference to local candidates and so if
you if your goal is to work at at a
smallest a sub you know twenty person
startup you're probably added I don't
know ten twenty precise advantage if
you're based in the Bay Area right there
okay cool so from the company side
there's like a million different
interview methods that people go for say
we are you know they go through triple
bite they get screened they're going to
do an interview whiteboarding pair
programming all that stuff how do you
feel about it all the toughest can work
the writer ahead let me let me let me
let me sort of give a bit of an overview
here um so again as I mentioned earlier
the core problem is there's this tension
between the skills that can be met in an
interview solving small problems quickly
and the skill that matters is a
programmer solving being project over
for a long period of time and so the
first you know the first approach you
can take interviewing is just say okay
we're going to we're going to not do it
we're going to do like trial employment
something like that yeah
and that totally works if you work
someone for a week you have a far better
read of their skill and I think anyone
can get during it during a three to four
hour interview the problem is that
there's a pretty strong bias and who's
willing to do trial employment
I mean as exid's adverse by so that some
of the so many of the best programmers
have lots of options and if your company
requires that everyone do this trial and
employment period most of them are not
gonna just gonna say no and obviously
anyone who currently has a job a family
for a way to do it can't leave for a
week yeah and of course is also you know
you're committing a week of time and so
obviously you need some filter before
the trial
you know employment and so I think in
the end we're left with a thing kind of
like that you know like the what the
famous you know democracy is the worst
form of government except for all the
others I think that you know any of yous
are the worst way to evaluate engineered
except for like all the other options
here yeah and so we're less of like you
have to do it it's fundamentally
inaccurate you still have to do it it's
because to make it as accurate as
possible um you know and so once once
you're on that page we see two sources
of noise we see noise that comes from
the companies being inconsistent so talk
about that a bit earlier mm-hmm um you
know just it is still too often the
process that engineer's are responsive
coming with their own questions
seems like you're asking every every
every candidate different questions and
again coming to a gut call they're just
like far larger than anyone really
realizes source of noise and so like if
you ask you know pick any company that
has that process you ask them to read
and somehow re-engineer we interview
their their colleagues you know in a
blind fashion right they would have a
you know it would likely have a fifty to
fifty percent pass rate right before
it's enter college would be screened out
um and so the solution there it's just
to be really consistent okay so like the
company like to make sure that you're
asking everyone the same question and
make sure that you're valuing it in the
same way and I think that's that's more
important than what you're actually
asking right so looked over the first
step is be consistent second step is
tweaked out over time based on what's
done on the results you see okay you
know once you're doing that I think the
other source of noise we see is
companies looking for different things
right so as an example if earlier you
have a company just looking for a super
academic you know engineers to pratical
engineers you have companies that think
that you know all skill engineers you
know about how operate systems work we
have company to think that you know they
only want people who's experienced and
compiled languages your company to hate
compiled Lakers I think they're opening
your companies to like want people to
use enterprise languages your company
because mess yeah and so I think the
important thing is to untangle which of
those are conscious decisions you're
making but you want to hire so your
banking company you want a big focused
on you know QA process and safe code it
probably makes sense the rejected one
for being to eat when to the cowboy you
know you're a social media company your
goal is to move really fast you know
maybe you decide to have a culture we
want to move faster break things and you
want to hire a Cowboys you know those
those those are all those are you know
logical decisions going on but it but
very often companies are making similar
kinds of decisions almost by accident
and so sort of introspection deciding
okay like there's all think about you
want to hire those people and then
designing the process to look for it and
so in your examples white word coding
tends to skew toward the academic it
tends to give preference to people who
are really good at breaking their
thoughts down into this sort of
structured academic way and write it
with a small amount of code so you often
have people who are actually really
productive excellent programmers who
look really stupid and bad on a
wakeboard interview and so if you're not
looking for academic skills it probably
makes more sense to put people on the
actual computer and see how they
actually work in their environment okay
and so what does the I get the
underlying question for me is like could
you engineer perfect interview but I
wonder like what is the interview for a
job at triple bite look like what I mean
I imagine you made it right yeah okay
well so first of all I want to go start
with all our candidates go through a
regular process okay so we hire there's
people out of our regular stream mmm we
compete at edits companies so they they
inter them to us as well as other
companies and which is kind of fun
so they first so so they first go
through a regular process and so we
already you know have a pretty strong
sense of how they are in those areas and
then just like you know but my advice
generally is to decide what what the
skills that that you preference mm-hmm
and so I think we we preference I a
couple things we preference and data
analysis is pretty key to our business
and so we preference people being
comfortable and familiar you know
talking and thinking about data that's
to use a bit more academic I think then
then then then what many companies hire
for
and then we because we're in the
business of evaluating knowledge really
broadly we then preference breadth of
knowledge I think to a greater degree
than those companies need to into what
what does that mean in practice like
what questions would I be would I be
looking at yeah so we again seven goes
through first our standard process yeah
and so we had that gives us a pretty
good read on just you know corrective
programming output general knowledge of
computer science geology custom design
and then we then in our we do additional
follow-up you know on site for the
candidates and that goes much more into
depth into into data or if we're hiring
them for a different role but sometimes
hire folks who'd are not working written
in your data so for hiring to be sort of
as a front-end developer sort of into
depth into front development mm-hmm and
so here that here's a you know here's a
spec for a front-end project you have
two hours build that or if they're gonna
be back in specialist here's a back-end
spec you know yeah sure okay and so as
an engineer should I be paying attention
to like every new thing that's coming
out is that going to be of importance
when I'm doing an interview or should I
be paying attention to whatever a medium
amount of it well we had this
interesting longer term and so it was
one thing a class people we see
interestingly we see people who have
whom who thought about that same thing
ten years ago right made the decision to
not keep up not now doing the serious
change and then these folks you know or
maybe still using let's say CGI and they
understand modern web stack and are
indeed in a weak situation in interviews
so I think answer your question is day
one it's not so important very few
companies especially only generally only
smaller ones are like directly
evaluating flashing your tech mmm-hmm
however if you if you if you make
decision two to four today and you know
don't give up the date and you'll get
your end up being you know totally
behind ten years from now then you
probably are gonna going to pay a price
yeah I mean especially if you're
actually interested in starting your own
thing at some point like being on the
edge really really matters okay
I uh I mean maybe this is kind of
difficult to answer but I wonder about
like employee retention engineer
retention are there any qualities that
you found
you can bet someone and say like okay I
think the average is like 18 months or
something for someone to stay around are
their qualities that correlate to longer
term employment I'm not having to start
date on this recently so there's gonna
be a little bit sort of off off the cuff
yeah I mean just the obvious things if
you know can dates you are excited about
the mission and the actual company you
have a you know higher probability of
staying than candidates who are chasing
nice paycheck because local examples you
know sometimes they're awesome engineers
who are looking for a place to really
commit but I also want to make a fairway
so it's a holiday this is all a
complicated but yeah look you're looking
for and I think I think I think the
number I think I'll just say looking for
engineers who are excited about about
the company and the job okay cool
so kind of just wrapping up I am I
wonder are there any books or things
that if I'm in kind of like an
engineering manager I'm going to be
running a bunch of interviews that I
should I should really dig into and I
can get a lot out of I have not actually
found any books and I think are very
useful I think we just found arrogant
maybe but I think engineer you bring a
search field where it's so easy to say
things that sound profound that are not
true okay I truly believe that like like
80% of what's written out the part
interviewing it doesn't actually call it
so for example yeah it sounded like a
really idea a lot of Engineers love
write is the statement that interviews
don't make any sense at all and you just
look at work someone has done in the
past and you know we test this a bunch
we tried to drive scoring engineers and
I haven't talked about past projects and
scoring them and try and even go even
like with like a full hour at going his
depth in the project during technical
details scoring it just talking skill
ability to spin a tale ended up
dominating the actual engineering rigor
and this was far or less predictive of
job performance than giving them a
relatively simple programming assignment
I mean and then it kind of sucks like I
don't really like that the case um you
can find so many articles up net about
about sort of you know this it's stupid
that we're asking engineers to do these
interviews why don't we just haven't
talked about their past experience I
just if you test it doesn't hold up and
just for the sake of like keeping
standard right
what do you tell people do in that way
when they're conducting an interview
well yeah yeah I mean your standardized
right so well you'd be really careful
helping people trustingly so great a
certain certain candidates are a lot
better at listening help without
necessarily realizing they were helping
them this is something we have added
with a bunch actually and so we have it
helps the review again we're doing
thousands of variation so it's easier
for us to do this but sort of being we
our Comment decision tree of all
different ways anybody can go and like
what help we're allowed to get my hope
or not allowed to get it just it's big
sorta noise outside of doing a thousand
interviews and standardizing I'm not
sure I have a really good fix for it but
be aware that some really compassionate
can dates will be like okay so okay so
what's the common area where I might ask
for help without you even realizing that
I'm getting help one is being brave
enough to ask
so saying like being really friendly
yeah and then we're saying something
with confidence that's that's sort of
like sort of right and then getting it
just natural instinct to like add on to
and correct the error and as the
interviewer it's really easy to do that
and not realize that you're like
steering the person through the problem
so if you're going after interviews you
should do exactly that there will be a
blog post on how to prep interview than
I do right like I recommend trying to do
that expertly
oh yeah I want to add a sort of a side
to that though yeah which is like
actually the negative side of that which
is that anybody could turn into hazing
anybody like another interview is not
just evaluation it's also like this
right of the shared right of entry into
a company and some company has developed
this culture around the interviews being
hard and unpleasant and as the
interviewer it's really easy to forget
how much harder it is with your the one
you were answering the question it's so
much easier to feel smart when you're
asking the question and sometimes
candidates get really flustered and like
answer a question and it seems likely
I'd like to be really frustrating at the
interviewer if they're like this thing
is obvious infront of them there's
missing it and the wasting your time and
you conduct you can get a bit angry
inside and it's just really important to
stay away from like the hazing but like
taking out anger on them by like like
you know
you know I'm generally against coming to
view short actually I think is I think I
think I think except were in the case
with any of you where the Kenda is in
pain I think it's not worth doing I
think you save some time but but you
damage repetition you know they
basically just like it's embarrassing
okay but definitely staying away from
the hazing staying away from like food
so does that just mean like crazy brain
teasers does that mean like cutting them
off and conversation what does that mean
yeah I mean it mean well it means all
those things right so it means crazy
brain teasers be mean thinking sort of
sort of sort of getting getting slightly
angry and and aggressive and how you
went to their questions because you're
frustrated by it by how poorly they're
doing okay and a trick that we use what
I think helps in that case is just sort
of in the case where Canada is totally
failing the interview like flipping a
switch in your brain and going from like
evaluation one to the teaching mode and
you're you're like full goal now is just
to explain and as friendly as positive
like generally any other person say
alright this happens when the person has
already essentially failed at least the
problem if not the interview sure so you
look you're already having it in the
brain happen okay this person is not
passing so I'm going to spend the
remaining 15 minutes being friendly and
explaining the answer to this question
sure rather than continuing to try to
elicit responses from them and what
about the just the dynamic like do you
advise one-on-one interviews or how many
people - per interviewee yeah I multiple
panels definitely creatures the stress
yeah so we max out at two to one so it's
in place training is important right so
if you trying to keep it consistent
you need to have continued across like
to cross if people need to watch each
other's interviews and so with it but to
sort of one interviewer one Shadower is
enough to do that you know going beyond
that increases the stress and I don't
think it really helps cool so if people
want to follow up with you and ask you
questions how can they reach out to you
sure
my email is I'm in a trilobite calm
that's eight mmon go thanks man thank
you
you